[Musique]
elle aurait pu rester médecin à
l'hôpital d'Orléan d'autant qu'elle
s'est toujours méfié des partis
politiques mais pour mener à bien la
mission qu'elle s'est fixé elle a fini
par s'engager en 2017 sous les couleurs
d'en
[Musique]
marche bonjour Stéphanie Rist bonjour
Alors vous siégez aujourd'hui au sein du
groupe Renaissance mais quand vous avez
envoyé votre CV à en marche en 2017 vous
étiez persuadé que vous ne seriez pas
retenu pourquoi oui je croyais que les
les cases enfin les les dés étaient
jetés à l'avance je pensais que les
postes étaient déjà pourvus c'était
c'estàd vous aviez une image de la
politique qui était quand même pas
formidable pour penser ça ouais j'avais
une image en tout cas que c'était
réservé à certains ouis soit parce
qu'ils étaient engagés depuis très tôt
dans des partis politiques
ou soit parce qu'il étaient il avaient
fait des études pour ça voilà l'idée de
d'être engagé dans un parti c'était pas
vraiment votre truc non j'étais pas
engagé dans un parti même si la chose
politique et et la politique en général
les débats m'intéressait déjà alors à
l'époque vous étiez donc médecin à
l'hôpital d'Orléan vous aviez jamais
fait de politique mais vous l'avez
emporté assez largement finalement au
législatif de de 2017 et le lendemain de
votre élection vous vous êtes montré
plutôt confiante on va revoir les image
vous êtes novice votre expérience vous
l'avez pas encor qu'est-ce qui fait que
vous allez être une bonne députée j'ai
un engagement qui est ancien un
engagement à l'intérieur de l'hôpital en
en milieu associatif et cet engagement
il se poursuit et pour moi c'est une
continuité sur mon parcours et certes
j'ai pas d'expérience politique pure
mais j'ai une expérience de de l'écoute
du partage de l'échange et de faire
avancer les sujets c'est assez
surprenant donc vous considérez que bah
votre mandat de député c'est un peu la
suite logique de votre engagement de
médecin pourquoi ouai c'était assez
cohérent parce que depuis plusieurs
années je travaillais à l'intérieur de
l'hôpital pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins de mon territoire en difficulté en
raison du nombre de de médecins depuis
nombreuses années et et et j'étais
arrivé au bout de ce que je pouvais
faire à à mon échelle à l'intérieur en
tant que médecin et donc j'avais envie
de m'engager pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins donc c'était déjà l'objectif que
vous étiez fixé en en présentant votre
votre candidature oua c'est vraiment le
sens premier de mon engagement c'est
c'est vraiment pour améliorer la vie des
gens sur la partie accès aux soins
puisque c'est là où j'ai le domaine de
compétenence on va on va en parler plus
en longueur dans un instant mais d'abord
sur le papier médecine et politique ça
semble très éloigné vous vous vous voyez
quand même des des points communs entre
les deux ah oui beaucoup en fait j'avais
peur que la médecine me manque en arrê
en arrêtant même si je fais encore une
demi-journée mais j'avais peur en fait
dans la politique vous continuez à
écouter les gens et à essayer
d'améliorer leur vie soit localement
quand ils viennent vous voir à la
permanence parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes donc vous essayez de les aider
soit même nationalement et dans les lois
qu'on peut porter ou les ou voter on
essaie d'améliorer la vie des gens il y
a une partie diagnostique une partie
soin y a une partie diagnostique il y a
une grosse partie écoute il y a une
partie je crois qu'il faut aimer les
gens si on veut faire de la politique
sinon ça ne marche pas à mon avis et
qu'est-ce qui est le plus facile d'entre
les deux le plus entre la médecine et la
politique je je crois que la la la
politique c'est énormément de travail et
ça m'a surpris d'ailleurs en arrivant la
quantité de travail que font tous les
députés quel que soit leur appartenance
politique il y a beaucoup d'engagement
et de travail la médecine aussi bien
évidemment j'ai beaucoup travaillé
pendant mes études on travaille beaucoup
mais en politique peut-être encore plus
encore quand on regarde le bilan de
votre action depuis 2017 presque toutes
vos initiatives sont tournées vers cet
objectif que vous avez évoqué améliorer
l'accès aux soins vous êtes même à
l'origine de deux lois hein de deux lois
que vous avez déposé qui ont été voté
sur ce sujet ça donne un peu
l'impression que vous êtes une députée
en mission vous vous retrouvez là-dedans
dans cette formule en tout cas en tout
cas je je sais pourquoi je suis là et et
je sais pourquoi je suis engagé et et en
même temps chacun doit apporter sur les
sujets dans le cadre de ses compétences
aussi dans ce qu'il a déjà vécu ses
expériences et et donc voilà donc moi
c'est la santé donc je m'engage sur la
santé et je travaille beaucoup pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses mais
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous vous
intéressez pas ou peu au reste que c'est
pas c'est pas votre truc c'est alors non
et ça c'est venu progressivement
c'est-à-dire quand je suis arrivée
j'étais pas dans la commission des
affaires sociales j'étais dans la
commission Affaires Culturelles
éducation et sport donc je me suis tout
de suite intéressée à d'autres sujets
finalement même si une partie de moi
rapportait très souvent au sujet santé
mais non donc c'est bien sûr sur tous
les textes parce que la vie des gens
quand ils viennent nous voir à la
permanence c'est pas que des problèmes
de santé mais ma spécificité est sur la
santé elle est sur la santé pendant le
débat sur la réforme des retraites vous
vous êtes retrouvé en première ligne
parce que vous avez été rapporteur de de
ce projet de loi on vous a vu répondre
aux différentes attaques des des
oppositions sur un registre purement
politique sauf une fois c'était en
réponse au au député rassemblement
national Thomas ménager on va revoir les
images là
aussi mon père a travaillé toute sa vie
sur les toits il est couvreur mon père a
58 ans aujourd'hui chaque soir à les
genoux qui doubl de volume chaque matin
est incapable de se lever parce qu'il
est cassé venez sur le terrain et vous
comprendrez que pour une partie des
Français il est impossible d'aller
jusqu'à 64 ans Monsieur ménager mon père
à moi il tenait un bist TR il se levait
tous les matins à 5h du mat il bossait 7
jours sur 7 personne ici a un monopole
du papa qui a souffert dans son dans sa
vie ah c'est assez rare que les députés
parlent d'euxmême de leur histoire
privée de leur vie familiale on peut
dire pourquoi vous l'z pourquo vous vous
avez fait ça au jour ce jour-là ouais je
crois qu'il faut remettre dans le
contexte d'une réforme compliquée qui
nécessitait beaucoup de travail avant et
et aussi une fatigue assez importante et
je crois que dans ces moments-là
finalement on on retire un peu les
barrières et et c'était une attaque av
beaucoup d'attaqu en fait c'était d'une
violence aussi vraiment importante au
ban dans cette réforme des retraites
avec des propos très virulent de de de
de plusieurs de de plusieurs bords euh
et et en fait je trouve que l'argument
était était personnel et qu'il fallait
répondre par du personnel en fait c'est
sorti tout seul je sais pas s'il y a
froid reposé j'aurais eu les mêmes
arguments je crois pas alors vous avez
été élevé éduqué dans un milieu plutôt
modeste on l'a compris en choisissant de
faire médecine vous avez donc fait bah
les études les plus longues qui existent
en France hein et vous dites que c'était
une forme de revanche pour vous une
revanche sur quoi oui j'ai j'ai j'ai des
parents qui ont tout mis on est deux
filles et et qui ont mis les études
comme quelque chose de de très important
et
d'émancipateur et euh parce que
eux-mêmes n pasê n'ont pas eu le bac et
et voilà mais c'est pas on en est pas
triste dans la famille voilà moi j'ai
une grande fierté je suis très fière de
de mes parents mais n'empêche que la
notion de de de faire des études et
d'avoir cette chance de pouvoir étudier
était était vraiment rabâé presque tous
les jours donc avec ma sœur on fait
effectivement chacune des études très
longues et je pense que c'est peut-être
en revanche par rapport à eux qui avait
pas pu faire d'étude donc vous avez
choisi médecine et pourtant la politique
vous a passionné très jeune dès l'âge de
7 ans vous regardiez l'heure de vérité
quand la plupart des enfants regardaient
plutôt le club doroté ah ouais non on
regardait l'ORS de vérité B avec mon
père et on on préparait vraiment
l'émission et on débattait sur les
sujets on essayait d'avoir un enfin
j'essayais d'avoir un
avisé i c'était vraiment sur le se
positionner par rapport avoir un avis
sur les choses qui nous entourent voilà
sur la société c'est pour ça que le le
sujet en politique pour moi n'est pas
que la santé mais tous les sujets
m'intéressent pour essayer de me
construire un avis et et le porter et
essayer de convaincre c'est peut-être
pour ça que au sein de l'hôpital vous
êtes un peu sorti du cadre purement
médical comme vous l'expliquez à un
moment à 41 ans vous avez repris vos
études vous avez fait un master à
Science Po là aussi c'était une façon
aussi peut-être de vous rapprocher de
l'engagement politique mais je me suis
dit que le déclic il avait peut-être eu
lieu un peu avant quand je suis tombé
sur cette déclaration de vous plus je
regardais la Chaîne Parlementaire plus
j'avais envie d'y aller c'estàdire que
vous seriez peut-être pas à l'Assemblée
sans LCP alors je sais pas mais en tout
cas je je regardais je regardais les
questions de gouvernement mais je
regardais aussi les séances la nuit et
et je me disais ils sont pas très
nombreux moi si j'y étais j'y serais
tout le temps sur les sièges voilà et
depuis vous avez un peu changé votre
façon de voir les choses et ben depuis
on comprend pourquoi tous les sièges ne
sont pas forcément remplis à longueore
de temps parce que il y a du travail en
commission parce que il y a des réunions
parce que est-ce queil y a aussi la
présence en circons c'est des choses
qu'on ne sait pas forcément quand on
regarde la télé alors il y a il y a peu
de députés he qui ont réussi à donner
leur nom à deux lois différentes en
aussi peu de temps vous avez fait voter
des mesures très concrètes pour la santé
par exemple le plafonnement des salaires
des des médecins intérimaires à
l'hôpital et pourtant vous dites avoir
été surprise par la difficulté à faire
bouger les choses en en politique
comment vous expliquez cette forme
d'inertie qui peut exister alors elle
s'explique d'une part pour une bonne
raison et une moins bonne la bonne
raison c'est à mon avis que il faut
emmener tous les acteurs et quand vous
touchez à un sujet en politique en fait
tout est tout se tient tout est engrainé
ça touche les finances ça touche
d'autres secteurs donc vous avez tous
ces gens-là à essayer d'emmener vers une
transformation une politique qui change
donc c'est normal que ça prenne un peu
de temps et puis il y a aussi une
lourdeur
administrative au changement culturel
aussi et parfois on aimerait que ça
aille beaucoup plus vite mais c'est
aussi notre boulot de député d'essayer
de de faire accélérer et bouger les les
lignes et et donc la la résistance au
changement en ce qui vous concerne elle
est venue en grande partie de vos
propres collègues
médecins qui ont pas franchement été
tendres avec vous est-ce que c'est pas
blessant de se battre pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins et d'être accusé par
une partie de la profession bah d'être
une trître alors c'est difficile au
début parce que en plus quand on est
médecin les gens vous aiment bien
généralement quand je fais ma
consultation lundi matin les gens m'aime
bien c'est c'est plutôt sympathique
quand vous arrivez en politique vous
comprenez qu'il y a des gens qui sont
pas d'accord avec vous et certains qui
ont une certaine violence et là sur les
lois que j'ai porté c'est vrai que ce
sont des lois qui
changent la culture qui bousculle ça a
été peut-être un peu rapide il y a eu
aussi des fausses informations qui
circulent enfin tout ce qu'on on
retrouve dès qu'on veut transform former
et faire avancer un peu plus vite
effectivement il y a il y a des propos
très violents encore une fois quand
s'attaque au député lui-même on s'y
attend he quand on va faire en politique
le premier truc qu'on vous dit c'est ça
va être dur mais mais quand ça touche la
famille par exemple là c'est vraiment
plus difficile dans les manifestations
de médecins libéraux il y a eu parfois
la pancarte riste tue et vous expliquez
que bah votre fille est tombé face à cet
affichage là dans la rue oui oui il y
avait un rassemblement avec cette
affiche
ma ma fille avec ses copines sont pass
pas loin en voyant ça c'est sûr que pour
elle c'était pas évident mais en même
temps maintenant elle commence à être un
peu habitué et ça leur fait aussi se
rendre compte de l'engagement de ce que
ça peut être même s'il faut pas
cautionner cette violence et cette
personnalisation parce que quand vous
faites une loi certes la loi porte mon
nom j'étais à l'initiative j'ai beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus mais mais on est
aussi une majorité puisque c'est des
lois qui ont été votées par presque
l'ensemble de de l'assemblée on va
passer à notre quiz à présent je vous
explique le principe je vais vous
proposer un début de phrase et ça va
être à vous euh de de le compléter on y
va en devenant député j'ai découvert que
que il fallait beaucoup travailler pour
faire bouger les lignes c'est un peu ce
que vous évoquez tout à l'heure depuis
que je suis élu ma famille me dit
souvent continue continue d'accord
malgré toutous ces attaques malgré leur
propre exposition parfois oua ouais j'ai
posé la question pour savoir si je
retourne
à
l'élection un deuxème mandat et ça a été
unanime enfin pour être ministre de la
santé il faut il faut le vouloir et en
tout cas pour ma part c'est pas ce qui
me fait me lever le matin moi ce qui me
fait lever le matin c'est améliorer les
choses s'il faut passer par cette case
pourquoi pas mais parce que votre nom a
circulé plusieurs fois lors des
remanimentss oui il y a toujours des
noms c'est normal je m'occupe des sujets
santé moi je je cherche pas un poste en
particulier je cherche à avancer les
sujets mais parfois ça passe par des
posts c'est vrai et ben on verra pour
ite merci beaucoup St d'avoir été
l'invité de la politique et moi merci
[Musique]
beaucoup